[Musique]
hier on a fait trois tonnes 950
nathalie est en pleine préparation de
commandes sa journée une fait que police
une journée type de nathalie c'est
debout 6h du matin on s'occupe des
enfants après j'arrive ici je fais mon
inventaire de frigo en jeu fait cueillir
le matin surtout les grappes parce que
les trois quarts de ma culture c'est de
la grappe
j'appelle les clients ans pour savoir
les commandes pour le lendemain
nathalie pèse chaque cage est que des
cueilleurs remplissent jusqu'aux
environs de 10 kg à charge pour elle de
vérifier grâce aux opérations
antérieures notamment l'élimination des
fleurs en surnombre l'opération est
facilité ensuite elle dépose sur des
palettes pour fournir la quantité
réclamé par chaque client
aujourd'hui on vend donc au grossiste en
bonbon aussi au supermarché on vend dans
les écoles en les cantines on vend aussi
pour les marchés et ben malheureusement
au mois d'août on a un peu trop de
tomates
il y en a dans les jardins heureusement
pour les gens on donne aux restos du
coeur le surplus qu'on n'arrive pas à
vendre
les commandes préparés sont livrés sous
24 heures maximum est conservé à 14
degrés pour éviter tout risque de perte
de goût
lasserre produit dix sept sortes de
tomates en quantité moindre que la
grappe presque du sur mesure pour des
clients très variés que nathalie et son
mari ont démarché un par un oui bonjour
et c'est les établissements la tomate
gourmande en fin prêt pour la commande
pour demain horticultrice de formation
nathalie s'est vite passionné pour cette
culture
cela fait huit ans que nous exerçons ce
métier en donnait un produit noble en
respectant
la nature en respectant le goût et la
qualité en c'est les premiers objectifs
qu'on s'est fixés et montrer aux gens
que les tomates sous serre ça a du goût
c'est comme le jardin pour juste
respecter le fruit en lui même
complètement en phase avec les tendances
actuelles du marché
les errants envisage déjà l'avenir il
faut investir pour se développer
si la serre fourni grâce à la
récupération de l'eau de pluie
le circuit nécessaires aux engrais ou
chauffage olivier se documente sur un
camion de livraison qui ferait diminuer
encore l'empreinte carbone de son
entreprise